did you know what you were doing when
you made that accidental mr chocolate
joke
i was about to call mr chocolate child
let me not do that child
i did not know what i this is what i
knew
i knew i had heard it but i didn't know
the context of it
and now it's like blowing up like
wildfire and i'm just like oh is that
what happened
dr wendy we are now a few episodes into
your housewives experience
how are you feeling about this variety
you signed yourself up for
it has been a ride i will say
that for sure um it has been fun though
it's so it's so interesting it's so
exciting
and so i love it i receive my bachelor's
degree in political science
i have my master of arts in government i
have my masters of science and public
policy
and i have my phd in community
development public affairs
i am also a professor at johns hopkins
university where i teach education and
policy
not to mention i'm also a political
commentator
slight work i think if people were to
look at your resume on paper
they would go why the hell did this
woman sign herself up for reality tv
so why the hell did this woman sign
herself up for reality tv
so i have like i have a few reasons i am
big on yellow like you only live once
do it plus the fact that i am big on
social justice
and what better platform to have to make
sure i get people out to vote
to let people know the importance of
their voice so i want to use the
platform
in that way so all good things your
worlds are colliding this week between
yes the dnc is happening and potomac is
airing you're having to go between
cable news appearances and interviews
like this how are you
balancing this whole circus that's kind
of what it is
it is such a delicate dance and i'm
trying my best to balance it i'm so glad
that you know the viewers get to see
everything that makes wendy wendy is not
just the glitz and the glam
it's also you know reading and the books
and making sure
everyone is aware of what's going on in
the world so i love it
reading and reading hello honey
who snaps read and read
something i found interesting since
you've become
part of the bravo sphere and people
realizing you go on fox news of all the
cable news channels are like
why are you going on fox news reason
you're going on is
we have to bring this message to people
who might not hear it in other places
absolutely whether you like it or not
they are the highest rated cable news
network
we may not watch it but someone is
watching it i go on fox news
because i am the counter i come in there
and i wear
all of my colors so to speak i'm a woman
i'm an
immigrant i'm a minority um you know i
i'm black i'm a mom i come in there and
i speak from those lenses and it's
really important for people
whether they want to hear it or not to
hear the news from someone like me
would you say it's accurate that you
take no bs and you're not afraid to call
people out on their bs
absolutely if i can hold the man who
resides at 1600 pennsylvania avenue
accountable then i can hold you
accountable
that's the type of friend i am take it
or leave it
and safe to say you will be holding
people accountable as the season goes on
and you get to know these women
absolutely
absolutely so is this a dinner for
ashley or a candace attack
what surprised you the most about this
experience
yeah i think it's really intense and
that's why it's so funny when people saw
me making all these faces because in my
head i'm like what
what are y'all doing did you know you
were so expressive before watching
yourself back on tv
you know what i've been told i don't
have a poker face but i
just didn't know to the extent i don't
have a poker face
i'm like i need to work on my face like
i think from now on
i'm just going to say i'm just going to
pick up my face
like you don't know you want to you want
to own this wendy you want to take this
and run with it and go with it and keep
making the strangest faces you possibly
can
i'm going to advise you to go the
opposite direction you're thinking okay
okay okay i'll take it were you a fan of
housewives in general before signing up
can i be honest yes the first time i
ever watched potomac well i watched
potomac once i was cast
on the show so i was like okay what
happened okay let me get up to speed
who are these people
but my mom watched potomac um she
definitely watched potomac so what did
susan think of the ladies did she give
you like
i want you to be friends with this one
this one's my favorite
she is so opinionated susan was like
listen
you you know i like candice but don't
treat me how she treats her mama i said
okay mom
but um it's really interesting when i
don't get things my mom is always like
well let me tell you the backstory of
how we got here i'm like okay mom what
happened
so she's like she's she's my cliff notes
yeah she's a good resource
well we've obviously seen you and
karen's relationship get off
to a rocky start winnie and i we've been
at events together we set on a board
together
and i'm not impressed and then it's
seeming to not get any better
i have nothing for karen like i'm like
let her
continue to you know say she doesn't
know me that's fine
because if she knew me she would know
not to mess with me
so you're right you don't know me let's
keep it like that aside from what
surprised you the most
who surprised you the most who surprised
me the most was actually karen
um i was surprised because i just
thought that she would be
you know just warm you know she she
portrays herself
as this motherly person that's not what
i got from her i'm not
a fan of people who go out of their way
to be mean to other people and so you
know
it's it's it's interesting because how i
define a queen
is someone who not only oversees their
kingdom but builds their kingdom
and so the only way you can build your
kingdom is for you to love the people
around you
and i just don't see that happening okay
i'll i'll take that and remember that
all season long
so that really surprised me and i will
also say ashley
actually surprised me but in a good way
maybe i just call her during a good time
super zen well that's a little
surprising to hear because in the teaser
for
the whole season we see at least two
tense moments with you and ashley
including the
bye wendy dr wendy address me correctly
sweetie
so what leads to that tension it's
actually because
it's two moms going at it and then it
rolled over
into another conversation and that's
where you guys see the doctor wendy
okay so maybe those moments aren't as
dramatic as they come across in that
trailer
they are okay they're still drunk maybe
they don't maybe they don't cut as deep
as we might think they're surface wounds
instead of
stab wounds okay this whole season seems
to be building to this big
fight when you go through that trailer
and you look at what footage we have you
were the person trying to push them
apart
and another wendy facial expression like
what the hell's going on
what was it like to be caught up in the
middle of that
you know what i like both candice and
moani and when i saw it escalating i
said you know i have a feeling where
this is gonna go but
as long as i'm around i don't want it to
go there it was heartbreaking
it was really something that just like i
wish that never happened if i had a
magic wand i would
i would make it go away but you know i'm
that girlfriend i'm that girlfriend that
if something happens i'm gonna be right
there to make sure
i got your back and i'm going to be
right there to protect you know both
people i won't run away
like some people did okay oh one person
did
one person ran away okay it seems like
that is going to change not just the
trajectory of the season but kind of the
trajectory of
this whole series that fight is like a
defining moment how would you say
that fight is going to impact where the
show goes from here
this season and future seasons oh my
goodness that's the watershed moment
that is the watershed moment of
atonement i believe that that's the
moment and that has been the moment
that has changed the dynamic of all the
relationships
and has changed it to the extent that
some people have said there's no turning
back i am hopeful
that we can come back together as a
group but whatever happens
from this point that moment is going to
be what defines it
it does seem like we are in a team
candace team monique
and you have to choose a side kind of
place
do you feel like you have to choose a
side no
and this is why i'm not team candace nor
team monique i'm team right
or wrong and that's where people are
getting messed up
anyone who tries to frame this as team
candace or team monique they they're
playing their hand
because it's not about that it's right
or wrong simple
and i've heard from your co-stars two
things i've heard there was nobody right
in that situation and that there was one
person who was right and there was one
person who was wrong
would you which side would you say are
two wrongs or one right one wrong
somewhere in the middle it's like one of
those things that you
you know and i want i want the viewers
to honestly
give their honest take on this and but
this is what i will say
you have to understand if i
if i kick you and then
you retaliate by throwing a grenade at
me it's
you have to decide is it too right two
wrongs or
was one person more wrong or one person
more right and that's what we're dealing
with here but for me
i just think it's about at the end of
the day whatever happens
accepting what happens and then saying i
will be
accountable for my own actions and what
i did
in this and apologizing if you feel like
you know apology
is is needed and then moving forward um
i i just yeah that's that's where i
stand on it
candace seems joe started the season in
a pretty messy spot with a number of the
women and it seems to only be getting
messier as we go
on we learn she's maybe talked some
trash on the women to you
i'm so ready that you're a monster oh
if she want to see that i'll be more
than happy to give it to her
sometimes you are not nice what can you
tell me about that
did you know candace to be this kind of
no you see so i didn't know candace to
be that and i
i don't know if it's necessarily trash
you stated you know you're
coming into this group here is some
primer for each of them
but she also stated to me very clear
these are my feelings i want you to go
in there and i want you to make your own
decisions and that's how that's really
what the conversation was i didn't see
necessarily anything wrong with it
because that's what any friend would do
she even said that with people who her
relationships were not so good with like
someone like ashley
she said this is how i feel but i want
you to meet her
and make up your own mind okay so maybe
what is being interpreted as messy isn't
as messy as it's coming across on tv and
there's some lost in translation there
stuff with candace
maybe maybe because it wasn't when she
delivered it to me i was like oh
no
[Laughter]
okay i loved on the most recent episode
we got to meet your family
i have my husband he is an attorney
eddie is nigerian american he's the
finest man i know he is just
child just just a piece of chocolate
i was about to call mr chocolate child
let me not do that child
[Laughter]
did you know what you were doing when
you made that accidental mr chocolate
joke
did it you know what's so funny you know
what's so funny i
did not know what i this is what i knew
i knew i had heard it but i didn't know
the context of it
so when i said it no not why i said if i
said he's a fine piece of chocolate
cause i always say that
and i said i will i was about to call
him mr chocolate oh no child
no i don't know because i don't remember
what it was connected to and now it's
like blowing up like wildfire
and i'm just like oh is that what
happened well because you
you brought something full circle in the
housewives universe so that's what was
interesting
so let me get this straight phaedra is
having an affair with some
african man named chocolate because i
know it's like phaedra jamal atlanta
it's a whole so people thought you have
been a little messy but you were just
trying to save yourself because you
didn't know i didn't know i i didn't
know and even if you hear my
cackle laughs afterwards i thought it
would it would be like an outtake like i
was like wait hold up child like i was
just talking about hold up children no
no
like and i did my belly laughs
i was not trying to be shady at all
but those are the moments that those are
the moments they're always going to
leave in
those are the moments all right we've
got a lot of season left to watch
what are you most excited for the
viewers to experience
oh on a personal note i am really
excited for the viewers to
get a glimpse of my inner life you will
actually be surprised how i feel
about my career and so i'm really
interested for the viewers to to hear
you know me and some of my struggles and
i'm really excited for the viewers to
see
our um international trip a lot of
buttons
are put on that trip are any buttons
pushed on the trip though
yes a new is
everything is tied up and a new one is
opened
okay is there anything you are scared to
see back on tv
or nervous for the viewers to see so
spoiler alert i have a potty mouth so i
just want to know how good
the bleeping is because i have a potty
mouth i'm just a little bit
nervous because even as old as i am
i'm still my mom's child susan doesn't
play so i
am nervous for some of the words i use
because she is going to call me
wendy you know my friends are watching
this wendy how
oh mom calm down hang up
you say mom you know your friends are
watching the real housewives
it is what it is not to borrow a phrase
from the man in 1600 pennsylvania avenue
but it is what it is
all right wendy anything else you want
the fans to know me to know before you
have to go and do another cable news
interview
um no i just want i just want to make
sure
everyone goes out and votes and if
you're registered to vote
make sure your loved ones are also
registered to vote it's so important
and request your mailing ballot early
and figure out where you can drop it off
in person
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello
you